[Musique]
c'est donc la première
ce soir de votre nouveau rendez vous
consacré à la présidentielle en france
france 2022 l'heure du choix d'abord
tous les lundis à 20h15 heure de paris
puis tous les soirs à la même heure à
partir du 14 mars avec nous à sereine
verdien bonsoir bonsoir audrey bonsoir à
vous tous vous avez bien raison de nous
rejoindre pour cette première cardon
france 2022 l'heure du choix on vous
propose un regard différent sur la
présidentielle en france à travers nos
reportages en france bien sûr mais aussi
à l'étranger grâce à notre réseau unique
de correspondants et à travers les
interventions des membres de notre
rédaction multiculturelle vous le savez
plus de 50 nationalités origine
différente ici à france 24 tout de suite
le sommaire de notre émission préparée
par florent rodo et fadil bayat
l'heure du choix
à trois mois de l'élection
présidentielle
nous vous proposons de suivre ce moment
fort de la vie politique française
bousculé cette année par la pandémie de
kobe 19
qu'attendent les français pouvoir
d'achat crise sanitaire éducation
politique étrangère climat sécurité
immigration
quel homme ou quelle femme politique
sera convaincre les électeurs nous
suivrons les candidats en meeting et
nous analyserons leur programme grâce à
notre réseau unique de correspondants
vous découvrirez comment ce scrutin
crucial pour l'avenir de la france est
perçue à l'étranger
90 jours de campagne deux jours de
scrutin
pour savoir qui sera le prochain
locataire de l'elysée
et en cette première semaine de 2022 la
campagne a enfin véritablement débuté
oui on ne s'est pas ennuyé audrey entre
la vraie-fausse entrée en campagne d'
emmanuel macron il ce gros mot qui a
beaucoup fait parler même fait
s'interroger la planète entière sur la
bonne traduction du terme emmerder dans
différentes langues il ya eu aussi des
galettes des rois personnaliser un
karcher resurgit du passé et même une
grève de la faim le récap politique de
la semaine signée florent rodo et
aurélien forget
c'est l'histoire d'une petite phrase qui
a fait grand bruit
[Musique]
emmanuel macron à une envie emmerder les
français n'ont vacciné
non seulement ils mettent en danger de
la vie d autres mais ils restreignent la
liberté des autres et ça je ne peux pas
l'accepter ces deux là étaient en froid
retrouvailles devant les caméras à
béziers pour marine le pen et robert
ménard mariage de raison avec l' envie
d'unir une extrême droite divisée le
choix c'est entre la vision nationale
que que je représente et la vision
mondialiste que représente emmanuel
zemmour après on a pris le risque
d'empêcher ce choix
un z comme zemmour
dégustation endiablé de galettes dans
l'eure et loir pour une rarissime
opération séduction dans le monde rural
merci à vous
elle veut nettoyer les quartiers retour
vers le futur pour valérie pécresse qui
ressort le kärcher de nicolas sarkozy
je traqueraient les caïds les voyous les
dealers les mafieux les prêcheurs de
haine alors oui je passerai le karcher
l'union de la gauche le député européen
pierre larrouturou la réclame quitte à
ne plus alimenter
cette primaire populaire anne hidalgo
n'en veux pas parce que l'écologiste
yannick jadot n'y va pas bien moi mon
sujet c'est pas de sauver le parti
socialiste c'est de sauver le climat
[Musique]
un climat maussade attend justement anne
hidalgo à jarnac où repose françois
mitterrand le bâtisseur de l'union de la
gauche cette gauche elle est non
seulement utile mais elle est
indispensable
utile
christiane taubira pense l'être
l'ancienne garde des sceaux solans la
primaire populaire ce sera bien avec
elle
voilà c'est tout pour cette semaine
vivement la prochaine
et dans tous les sondages sept emmanuel
macron qui est pour l'heure en tête on
va maintenant parler de la stratégie du
président presque candidat avec vous
roselyne febvre et je le rappelle vous
est la chef du service politique de
france 24 bonsoir roseline chartrain
gomes qui manuel macron prépare sa
campagne et bien tout se passe à
l'elysée au palais de l'élysée autour du
tout puissant secrétaire général alexis
et colère alors efficace pour les uns
redouté par certains est trop techno
pour les autres alors à quatre mois du
premier tour de la présidentielle le
magazine le point raconte comment
s'organise cette stratégie autour du
chef de l'état et le tout chapeauté par
alexis colère alors la question cruciale
dans le fond c'est que faire de nouveau
après avoir passé cinq ans au pouvoir
quel concept inventé on a connu le en
même temps bien sûr qui est bien
pratique pour emmanuel macron une fois à
gauche une fois à droite la révolution
titre de son livre en 2016 mais une
révolution qu'on n'a pas encore vu et
puis l'autre slogan
protéger et libérer le président a
surtout plutôt protégé avec le co vite
que libérer puisqu'il voulait libérer le
travail même s'il a fait une première
loi il voulait aller plus loin avec les
réformes des retraites on le sait alors
que fait alexis colère et bien il réunit
les crânes d'oeuf les cerveaux les
techno les experts des conseillers des
hauts fonctionnaires et on reprend de
même certains de la bande de 2000 qui
avait fait 2010 est ce qu'on surnommait
les mormons pourquoi les mormons alors
du nom de ce mouvement religieux connu
pour sa vision quasi monacale et surtout
cette capacité de travail acharné dont
ismaël et mes liens et david amiel était
la cheville les chevilles ouvrières
alors du côté des idées roselyne on
réfléchit à quoi et bien la fameuse
réforme des retraites comment
l'amener autrement sans froisser tous
les syndicats la santé trouver des
thèmes porteurs sur l'école sur la
laïcité on est allé chercher à rachel
kahn on cherche la martingale bref on
cherche des idées ça fume au dessus des
crânes de l'elysée avec un axiome de
base se renouveler et ce n'est pas
évident cinq ans après il ya aussi une
autre ruche qui travaillent à l'elysée
oui et cette fois sur le ce qu'on
appelle le récit national français que
raconte ont en quelque sorte aux
français c'est ce que le conseiller
mémoire d' emmanuel macron bruno
roger-petit appelle le récit de
l'imaginaire français et c'est ce que
raconte justement aussi il faut lire des
magazines cette semaine le magazine
valeurs actuelles hebdomadaire très à
droite alors trois personnages la plume
d'emmanuel macron son conseiller mémoire
que je viens de citer son directeur de
la com sont chargés de donner à emmanuel
macron le fil de ce récit de cet
imaginaire français alors on se souvient
que mitterrand disait les français
élisent celui qui raconte une histoire à
condition d'être légitime à le faire
alors cette histoire à la commande a
commencé depuis depuis longtemps ça a
commencé par aussi les fameux héros
positifs alors lorsqu'il ya eu des
drames qu'avec arnaud beltrame ont
suscité un an faisait sortir l'idée du
héros positifs la panthéonisation de
joséphine baker qui a choisi la france
donc la communion mémorielle cette
notion encore deux héros positifs la
transmission l'idée de l'émancipation se
projeter dans le monde et surtout donner
le sentiment aux français que le
président a compris quelque chose des
français qui se sentent dépossédés
dépossédé de quoi parce que le thème de
la dépossession et très important chez
les français par la mondialisation c'est
à dire que l'état et l'europe ne protège
pas assez des possessions économique et
sociale et aussi des positions culturel
avec le rocchi sme bref autant de thèmes
qui sont justement le narratif du
président ce qu'on a vu tout au long de
son quinquennat et qui aujourd'hui est
bien est en quelque sorte le le résumé
que veut faire emmanuel macron d'une
france qui a qui a une vision d'un
président qui a une vision et c'était
l'édito de roselyne febvre merci
beaucoup roselyne et je rajoute qu on
peut vous retrouvez dorénavant tous les
mardis dans une version longue de votre
émission mardi politique jusqu'au second
tour demain avec rfi
surréaliste pour certains essentiels
pour d'autres la polémique autour du
drapeau européen sous l'arc de triomphe
a fait réagir quasiment l'intégralité a
de la classe politique oui audrey
emmanuel macron voulait marquer les
esprits pour le début de sa présidence
du conseil de lieux c'est chose faite il
a aussi reçu les représentants de la
commission européenne à paris juste
avant le week end alors comment la
double casquette du président presque
candidat et l appréhender à bruxelles on
va voir ça avec alix le bourdon
bienvenue dans la capitale des
institutions européennes ou l'année
démarre ici avec un petit air de france
puisque c'est paris qui assume la
présidence tournante de l'union
européenne pendant six mois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais cette présidence tournante est
entrecoupé du scrutin présidentiel en
france alors comment l'envisagent ton à
bruxelles on voit ça avec nos deux
invités
ça c'est sûr mais on attend beaucoup des
manuels bas prix mais est-ce que c'est
gagnons un profil aussi europhiles
tentent pas si ces gagnants mais de
toute façon je me rappelle il y a cinq
ans après la victoire d emmanuel macron
il y avait des commentaires en allemagne
disant tiens on peut même gagner une
campagne électorale avec europe au
centre de cette campagne le respect de
l'état de droit ça va être au coeur du
programme de cette présidence française
de l'union européenne ça va sans doute
être aussi un sujet dans cette campagne
pour l'élection présidentielle
quelle posture à votre avis les
différents candidats peuvent adopter
face à ce thème la posture des manuels
macro est bien connu il a essayé de
faire avancer les choses il n'a pas
réussi c'est d'autant plus difficile
parce que nous avons vu tous les
candidats de la droite en france prendre
position par rapport à cette thématique
valérie pécresse a salué la décision du
tribunal constitutionnel polonais sur la
primauté du droit communautaire et puis
aussi marine le pen qui a elle aussi à
l'enseigné vision pourquoi pas de la
constitution française même chose je
pense pour les autres candidats eric
zemmour et d'autres et donc c'est
beaucoup plus difficile pour emmanuel
macron de se positionner étant donné
qu'il ya un contre discours sur ce même
sujet le problème avec l'extrême droite
c'est plus question d'équité la l'union
européenne on va changer l'union de
l'intérieur c'est l'idée de marine le
pen c'est aussi d'aider de victor là se
trouve le problème que l'extrême droite
bat ensemble pendant que ces valeurs en
europe de l'ouest
[Musique]
ont la présidence française de l'union
européenne génère beaucoup d'attentes
avec emmanuel macron de fervent
défenseur des idées européennes mais il
demeure une incertitude si un candidat -
europhile venait à être élu au printemps
au delà même de l'europe la politique
étrangère n'est pas franchement un sujet
qui domine ni dans les programmes ni
dans les débats oui pourtant andrey les
prétendants à l'elysée ont déjà consacré
du temps de campagne à des déplacements
à l'étranger hongrie arménie ou encore
côte d'ivoire ça c'était pour eric
zemmour pendant les fêtes la côte
d'ivoire où vous allez le voir la
présidentielle française intéresse
beaucoup la population reportage de
samuel bernard et damien koffi
à abidjan la capitale économique de la
côte d'ivoire paris est à 4800 km y
portant l'actualité française n'est
jamais très loin ici on ne connaît pas
tous les prétendants à l'elysée
seulement les cuves et éthiques
madame à caen et à 1 qui arrivaient
encore des vaches est pas trop sans nom
eric zemmour je pense déjà à mélenchon
la dame qui voulait s'opposer à amar'e
marine le pen dans les cafés parler de
politique fait partie du quotidien entre
amis on discute le plus souvent des
informations locales mais aussi plus
étonnant de politique française
quand on a vu les médias en parlent et
puis bon on a suivi on est dans le monde
ne peut pas ignorer les autres endroits
donc par moments et nous arrive d'en
parler voilà voilà les élections de la
france intéresse forcément la côte
d'ivoire parce que c'est un impact
humain un impact lié aux liens
historiques culturels mais aussi
économique entre les deux pays la france
reste le troisième partenaire commercial
après la chine et le nigeria pour ce
politologue l'un des thèmes majeurs de
ce début de campagne présidentielle
française intéresse fortement les
ivoiriens la question migratoire si
c'est la droite radicale la politique a
mise en oeuvre et sera préjudiciable
aux africains par contre si nous avons
la droite républicaine
incarné par valérie pécresse des
républicains ou bien même en marquant ce
sera le statu quo environ 75 mille
ivoiriens vivent actuellement en france
une communauté qui elle suivra d'encore
plus près cette prochaine échéance
électorale
retour en france à présent et direction
la campagne française oui jusqu'à la
présidentielle on va se rendre dans
différentes régions pour prendre le
pouls du pays à travers des portraits de
français de tous milieux
socioprofessionnels ont par cette
semaine en normandie à la rencontre
d'une éleveuse bovine véronique fournier
un portrait réalisé par julie d'une de
l'offre et florence wimille
viola là
rabon nyala
possible
ah le voilà les premières vaches sont
arrivés j'avais 24 ans
aujourd'hui j'ai une petite quarantaine
de vaches
quand je viens travailler même si c'est
à 2 heures du matin dans des conditions
difficiles je n'ai pas l'impression de
travailler
[Musique]
je lève entre 4h30 et 5h
j'attaque les vaches à 5h30 6 heures
viala ce qui me plaît le plus c'est les
animaux c'est le contact quand ça
réussit bien qu'on a fait enlever l'ag
que et que la petite bête s'en sort
c'est comme du manque de la famille
les vingt dernières années tout a été
chamboulé je suis arrivé il ya 38 ans il
y avait beaucoup de petites fermes ici
de petites productions laitières et
c'est fini
pour ce qui concerne les finances c'est
très très difficile mais bon il ya des
sacrifices à faire ça faut pas se
leurrer des foires crois qu'on ne va pas
en sortir on voit pas le bout
j'ai heureusement les aides pac de
bruxelles il faut garder cette pac pour
nous aider comme ça on sera toujours
indépendant des autres pays pour notre
pour notre nourriture c'est essentiel
[Musique]
la priorité ce qu'on reste indépendant
ne pas être absorbé par les grosses
usines agroalimentaires qui nous
affament par exemple avec les les prix
qui nous oblige à pratiquer ce bien
respecter l'environnement les animaux
qu'on laisse aller aux générations
futures quelque chose de propre
elle est une petite image d'archivé
maintenant c'est le bonus h rennes et
ces cas d'audrey une archive qui date du
24 octobre 1980 coluche revient sur sa
brève carrière politique et cet extrait
est un petit clin d'oeil vous allez voir
à l'acte politique de la semaine
regarder
non moi tout ce que je voulais c'était
en garder un peu j'y suis arrivé je suis
bien content mais j'ai pas eu intention
d'être président de la république
et c'est la fin de france 2022 l'heure
du choix merci infiniment à lise
barcellini roselyne febvre florent rodo
fadil bayat et amaury guibert pour la
préparation de cette émission merci
beaucoup h rennes cette émission est à
retrouver sur notre site internet france
24 points comme sur les réseaux sociaux
rendez vous lundi prochain à la même
heure à lundi on marque une courte pause
et on se retrouve dans un instant